you talked to khloe kardashian and you
said i'm pronouncing her name we're all
been pronouncing her name wrong
this whole time it's chloe chloe is the
name there's a little
accent over the name wait what wait wait
i'm so sorry no no i'm sorry
no no no sorry sorry but yeah i'm sorry
too but
call her i will call her i walked in i
go chloe and the other
women go excuse me and chris said
yeah that's actually really how it's
pronounced
yeah according to andy cohen we've all
been pronouncing chloe
or should we say chloe kardashian's name
wrong
all these years isn't that crazy but
have we really let's rewind the tapes
i'm chloe yeah chloe introduced herself
to us
all those years ago on the keeping up
with the kardashians series premiere
as chloe i'm chloe chloe i got the memo
chloe so to quote oprah what is the
truth
we might find out on andy cohen's new
show
for real the story of reality tv what is
andy cohen doing here
he sat down with the kardashians and
more famous faces from the world of
unscripted
television to get their unfiltered take
on what makes the genre
so addicting especially when it comes to
the kardashians
something e.t unpacked a little too with
the housewives maestro
it was really cool going to the set
of um the kardashians you know it was
wild it was so surreal
being in chloe's backyard and seeing the
candy jars
and they're all made up and i just had
to find out like how long they had all
been in hair and makeup before
they went over there and um it was
it was wild say what you will about that
family i mean the content number one
that they've given us alone
and the the the hustle that they've had
and the empire that they've built i mean
they could do college courses on them
seriously what surprised you the most
about chris and the girls
and kind of their journey i think how
involved they are
what we talked about you know we talked
about how involved they are behind the
scenes of the show
they are sent rough cuts of every
episode of the show and they
all look at them and um
give notes on them and it's it's really
interesting uh
there it's they're not they're partners
they're not uh they're not passive
observers
which is why i think the idea of kris
jenner becoming a real housewife is
actually inconceivable because you don't
go
from a show where you have all the power
and final
cut control you have control of what
gets on the air
to an ensemble show where you're one of
six women
who just uh goes in and films and
that's it you have no control but she
did say she would want to be a friend
right and then kim said she would die to
be on the show and you couldn't pass
that
up it's so true it's so true would you i
mean are you oh i mean we've seen her on
but are you yeah i mean well the great
are you open to that
friends with kyle and she's friends with
lisa rinna and she knows these women so
the answer is yeah i'd love it yeah what
about kim
i mean listen now you're you're
you're backing up the dump truck of
money i mean
that's true